hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast European pharmacopoeia
and complete toc oxidation for purified
water and water for injection presented
by Tony Harrison we're excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
Beckman Coulter life sciences Beckman
culture life sciences develops
manufactures and markets products that
simplify automate and innovate complex
biomedical testing more than two hundred
and seventy-five thousand Beckman
culture systems operate in both
diagnostics and life sciences
laboratories on seven continents for
over 75 years our products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving the productivity of medical
professionals and scientists supplying
critical information for improving
patient health and delivering trusted
solutions for research and discovery to
learn more about Beth men culture life
sciences please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor for today's event
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive and
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the green Q&A button
located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you'll be viewing the presentation
in the slide window to enlarge the
window just click on the screen icon
located on the lower right finally if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce Tony Harrison a senior
marketing manager at Beckman Coulter
life sciences Tony is experienced in
water system total organic carbon
conductivity ozone analysis cleanroom
environmental monitoring and part of
characterization he has spent the last
15 years in applied metrology for the
pharmaceutical and healthcare
manufacturing industries Tony he'll be
convener ship of the ISO working group
revising ISO one four six nine eight one
and two for microbial control in clean
rooms he served as the UK subject matter
expert to the ISO working group that
issued the 2015 revised versions of the
ISO one four six four four - one and two
documents for cleanroom classification
these were at the heart of the aseptic
manufacturing chapters of the European
GMP and the USA cGMP documents
tony was joint editor on the is PE guide
to ozone sanitization of pharmaceutical
water systems and was also chief editor
of the PHS s best practice guide for
cleanroom monitoring Tony is a well
known international speaker and has
provided educational seminars around the
globe on TOC liquid particle counting
ozone sanitization for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring his complete bio is
found on the labyrinth website please
join me in welcoming Tony Harrison I
will now turn the presentation over to
him thank you very much indeed for that
introduction hello everybody my name is
Tony Harrison from Beckman Coulter life
sciences today I'm going to discuss in
this very short presentation the
recommendations in the chapter two point
two point four four of the European
pharmacopoeia the total organic carbon
analyzer designed for measuring purified
water and water for injection should
fully oxidize the organic contaminants
the carbon dioxide to release the
organic carbon for accurate TOC
measurement now as I said this is a
relatively short presentation lasting
approximately 20 minutes depending on
questions and answers first we'll
discuss exactly what total organic
carbon is and then we'll move on to take
a quick look at the recent changes to
the European pharmacopoeia chapter on
water for injection and how this is
increasing the importance of accurate
TOC analysis
then we'll examine one of the key
problems stopping us carrying out
root-cause investigations on TOC
excursions and next we'll discuss the
European pharmacopoeia Chapter two point
two point four four on TOC and why it
calls for complete oxidation of the
organics for accurate TOC analysis
finally today we'll take a look at the
DAT 700 TOC and conductivity analyzer
from Beckman culture in the light of the
European farmer curry from Mecca Pierce
or Islamic appear requirements for
complete oxidation so let's take a look
at total organic carbon just what it is
and how its actually measured the FDA
mandate for critical water quality
attributes for water for injection and
purified water inorganic contaminants
should be measured total organic carbon
endotoxins
and microbial Corney forming units
should all be monitored total organic
carbon and conductivity are the only
real-time measurements amongst these
four and can give almost instant warning
of a potential contamination event our
total organic carbon measurement it's a
nonspecific test the results are a TOC
analysis can tell you the amount of
organic carbon in the water but it
cannot tell you exactly what the organic
contaminants present our TOC is in fact
a measurement of the mass of carbon
atoms present in organic material in the
water
reporting TOC in units of mass per liter
of water
ie micrograms per liter or more
frequently in the pharmaceutical
industry expressed as parts per billion
the carbon atoms are released from the
organic molecule by breaking the
molecule down through oxidation the
carbon forms into carbon dioxide which
in turn dissolves into the water
creating carbonic acid which is very
weak acid but it elevates the water
samples conductivity before the TOC is
measured the TOC analyzer must first
measure the amount of NAT
reoccuring dissolved carbon dioxide in
the water this is called the total
inorganic carbon and then the organics
are oxidized to release the carbon bay
contain and the total carbon is measured
by subtracting totally inorganic carbon
from total carbon the level of total
organic carbon in the water can be
ascertained
now TOC analyzers that utilize
conductivity to measure the organic
carbon can also be used to measure
conductivity one of the other parameters
however the farm that appears on very
specific regarding calibration of
conductivity analyzers and the TOC
analyzer itself would need to comply
fully with their requirements so for
example the United States chapter on on
conductivity u.s. p645 it's very clear
that the conductivity meter cell
constant must be verified against a
certified conductivity solution and also
that the meter electronics must be
verified by the use of a certified
calibration resistor since the changes
to the european pharmacopoeia chapter on
water injection in 2016 total organic
carbon is taken on an even more critical
role in detecting potential water
contamination events although much work
has been done in the last decade to
harmonize the folic appears the european
pharmacopoeia chapter on water
injections stood out because it's
specifically called for the use of a
steel for the manufacture of water
injection other Pharma Kabir's merely
listed the key quality parameters of
water injection which are of course
total organic carbon conductivity
microbial colony forming units and
endotoxin levels however was pressure to
reduce carbon footprints and reduced
manufacturing overheads representatives
from the united states pharmacopeia
the european pharmacopoeia and the
japanese pharmacopoeia came together to
survey the pharmaceutical industry
regarding the quality of water
manufactured by reverse osmosis and in
particular the level of control these
water treatment
plants had over microbial colony forming
units during the period from 2004 to
2010 the jpu SP and EP gathered surveys
on water for injection made from reverse
osmosis from around the world the
results were surprisingly good we've
many studies showing an excellent water
quality matching water for injection
standards and with very good levels of
microbial colony forming units control
so in 2011 an expert what workshop was
formed with representation from the
pharmaceutical manufacturing industry to
consider changing the European chapter
on water for injection to allow the use
of reverse osmosis as long as the water
produced of course met the key quality
attributes of water injection and showed
high levels of microbial control and
finally satisfied with their work in
2016 the new chapter for water injection
in the European pharmacopoeia was
adopted allowing for the first time the
use of reverse osmosis for the
production of water for injection now
the working party who supported the
European Directorate with their 2016 new
chapter for water injection made very
clear that they warned that reverse
osmosis water treatment may well not be
as robust as a still and they
highlighted the role of total organic
carbon and conductivity analyzers as
early detectors of potential impending
microbial or even endotoxin excursion
events naturally any total organic
carbon or conductivity excursion should
lead to a root cause investigation but
many excursions are transient in nature
and it is often difficult to capture a
sample of the contaminated water to
carry out the root cause investigation
so here's an example the problem is that
toc excursions as I said can often be
transient events now they detected by
the TOC Mis online but they disappear by
the time the team comes to take the
water sample
the root cause investigation as stated
earlier one parts-per-billion of carbon
is equivalent to one microgram of carbon
in one liter of water so in the example
here typical is an example of a modern
water injection system the toc levels
are commonly recorded at around 26 parts
per billion now say suddenly a slug of
total organic carbon is fed into the
water system by accident either from one
of the points of use or from a biofilm
shedding and this causes an excursion of
750 ppb on all the other points of use
equivalent to 750 micrograms of carbon
in one liter of water now the online TOC
analyser detects this and reports it as
an excursion and then the 750 ppb of
Mike or micrograms of carbon now enters
the water for injection storage tank
which in our example contains a thousand
liters of water injection so now the 750
micrograms of carbon is diluted in that
1000 liters of water injection and
actually becomes point sound 5
micrograms per liter of carbon or 0.75
ppb then this diluted carbon is very
easily destroyed by the UV lamp which is
commonly used for microbial control of
water for injection systems as the water
passes back out into the distribution
loop and now the TOC levels in lupa
return to their safe flow TOC value but
is too late
during us excursion levels of TOC at the
points of use were outside the
pharmacopoeia limits and any batch is
being manufactured at that time cannot
be released into the market and I said
what makes the situation worse it's just
no way to carry out a root cause
analysis to find out the likely sources
of the TOC excursion as all the evidence
has been diluted and destroyed so
there's no way to put a preventative
action in place to stop recurrence of
the excursion again at a later date and
this therefore could compromise the
future batches as well
so to the center of this presentation
today if online TOC analyzers are truly
to be used provide supporting batch
release data then there are some
significant issues to consider and not
least of which is complete oxidation of
the organic contaminants in the sample
to ensure accurate TOC measurement now
this is an excerpt from the text of the
European pharmacopoeia chapter on total
organic carbon chapter two point two
point four four it emphasizes the
importance of ensuring the complete
oxidation of the organic molecules to be
sure that all organic carbon present is
released and measured accurately most
TOC analyzers used to monitor
pharmaceutical grade water use
ultraviolet light to create hydroxyl
radicals from the water which in turn
oxidize the organic material present
releasing the carbon atoms in the form
of carbon dioxide as I mentioned the
carbon dioxide dissolves into the water
creating carbonic acid which elevates
the conductivity and this change in
conductivity is measured by the TOC
analyzer and used to calculate the
amount of organic carbon present in the
water the problem is that as long
complex chain molecules are broken down
during the oxidation process they may
form organic acids as intermediate
species which in fact will contribute
more strongly to the water conductivity
in the final carbon dioxide does if the
TOC analyzer does not complete the
oxidation of the organic molecule then
one of two things may happen either the
carbon remains bound inside the organic
and cannot be measured so that TOC is
underreported or the TOC analyzer takes
a conductivity measurement before the
complete oxidation when the organic
acids are present and it over approached
the amount of TOC in the water either
way of showing complete oxidation to
carbon dioxide is the only way to
measure TOC accurately
now some TOC analyzers are have a fixed
oxidation time the water continuously
flows through them and is only exposed
to the ultraviolet light for short
periods of time now these can struggle
to report.toc levels accurately the
International Conference on
harmonization is an expert working group
with representation from the European
the United States and the Japanese
pharmacopoeias and in their IC HQ to
document validation of analytical
procedures they recommend a system
suitability test to determine the
robustness of an analyzers measurement
sure the TOC analyzer with fixed
oxidation times be calibrated with a
relatively easy to oxidize TOC standard
such as sucrose and is likely not report
accurately if challenged with a
relatively difficult to oxidize TOC
standard such as the sBBs system
suitability test as recommended in the
Japanese drama compare chapter on TOC
the fix flow path and fixed exposure
times in the UV light will mean the SDB
s will not be fully oxidized and much of
the carbon will remain on measured now
some TOC analyzers employ persulphate as
well as the UV light now the persulphate
extends their measurement range and in
the presence of UV light that
persulphate becomes a very very strong
oxidizing agent enabling the TOC
analyzer to oxidize relatively large
amounts of TOC in a short time however
in designs employing gas selective
membranes as part of the measurement
cell this can present some challenges if
too much of a sulfate is added then
there's a danger that bubbles may form
in a sample when these bubbles can
occlude or block the measurement
membranes leading to underreporting of
TOC levels and equally is too little for
sulfate is added then the TS TOC may not
be fully oxidized and once more the TOC
analyzer will under report the TOC
content in the sample in the
paradoxical situation the analyzer user
somehow has to know in advance the value
of toc in the sample so they can
configure that the sulphate dosing
correctly on the analyzer before they
carry out the measurement so let's take
a look at the pea 8700 TOC and
conductivity analyzer from Beckman
quarter and see how he can help
compliance to the European pharmacopoeia
requirements
now this analyzer is not a
general-purpose analyzer it is designed
specifically for TOC analysis on
purified water and water for injection
and the p80
TOC analyzed from Beckman Coulter
employs the variable oxidation time
combined with a dynamic endpoint
detection to determine when the sample
oxidation is complete firstly an aliquot
of the water being sampled is tracked in
the measurement cell there's a single
conductivity sensor that measures the
conductivity of the sample which is
representative of the TI C totally
inorganic carbon in the sample a UV lamp
isn't turned on to oxidize the organic
since ample as the molecules are
oxidized the released organic carbon in
the sample turns to carbon dioxide which
dissolves and increases the conductivity
of the trapped aliquot of water the p80
700 monitors the change in conductivity
of the sample and when the conductivity
stops changing the p80 700 knows the
analysis endpoint has been reached and
the sample has been completely oxidized
now the sample contains both the TI C
took a look inorganic carbon and the
total organic : ie it's got total con
total carbon conductivity is measured
using the same conductivity sensor used
to measure the inorganic carbon and one
is subtracted from the other to
calculate total organic carbon by using
a single sensor to measure both the
inorganic and total carbon the effects
of any slight conductivity sensor drift
over time on the accuracy of the toc
calculation is eliminated as the
conductivity sensor driftwood
equally to both the inorganic carbon and
the total carbon measurement and thus
cancel out as the oxidation time with
the P 8,700 is variable and controlled
by done any dynamic endpoint detection
the analysis of harder to oxidize
materials such as best BBS as
recommended in the system suitability
test in the Japanese pharmacopoeia does
not cause a problem the P 8,700 simply
extends its analysis time continuing to
oxidize until it detects sample
conductivity has stopped changing and
the oxidation is complete now of course
these analyzers use ultraviolet light to
oxidize the organic so the level of the
ultraviolet light being emitted from the
UV lamp is critical and in the P 8700 it
is measured to ensure that it is
sufficiently powerful to oxidize the
sample and in the event of a lamp
failure a second standby UV lamp is
turned on to ensure complete observation
now as I mentioned earlier TOC or Condon
conductivity contamination events can be
transient in nature as I mentioned a
system that's experiencing gradual
biofilm buildup may experience TOC
excursions particularly just after the
sanitization cycles as biofilms lofts
off the inside of the pipe type work
this excursion can quickly disappear
either by doing diluted as it passes
into the loop storage tank or broken
down by UV lamps connected to the
pipework distribution network put in
place to discourage microbe you'll build
up however this rapid disappearance may
mask the increasing biofilm build-up
until there is a serious breakdown of
system control and runaway microbial
contamination to help with root cause
investigation the P 8700 can be
programmed to capture a water sample
should a toc excursion be detected so
the sample can be further analyzed to
get to root cause hence supporting Kappa
and one of the additional advantages
dynamic endpoint detection for complete
dog station in the p80 700 from Beckman
Coulter is that it can provide an
indication of the oxidation curve
profile during each TOC analysis each
organic will have a slightly different
oxidation profile so a change in the
type of profile combined with a changing
TOC levels may provide insight into a
change in the water system organic
chemistry
suggesting a potential degradation of
the reverse osmosis system integrity
prompting the user to investigate
further and consider corrective action
to prevent a large sell can scale
contamination event and to put in place
preventative measures to avoid the
recurrence of the problem in the future
so I've learned today that TOC and
conductivity analyzers can be strong
allies to help us keep our water systems
under control we've learned how
calibration is important and how
complete oxidation is recommended by the
European pharmacopoeia for accurate TOC
analysis so let's just summarize how the
p80 700 TOC in conduct on to continuity
Analects analyzer can support you
through the challenges of moving towards
for injection release so as leading edge
indicates the potential changes in water
system health online TOC and
conductivity analyzers are taking it
ever increasing importance and
preventing contamination contaminated
purified water and water for injection
from mixing with expensive expensive
drug product during manufacturing the
ability to report changes in water
organic chemistry combined with TOC
transient excursion capture provides
more support for root cause
investigations before the purified water
or the water water injection exceed the
pharmacopoeia limits complete TOC
oxidation to release all of the organic
carbon is carbon dioxide
even with long-chain difficult to
oxidize organic molecules as per the
European chapter two point two point
four four is paramount to accurate TOC
measurements if they're to be made
so now that concludes my talk today I'd
be happy to take any questions but I
would mentioned that there should be a
poll question posted on your screen to
ask you if you'd like to receive my
white paper on this subject if you would
like to receive that paper please click
on the yes and submit it so now I'm
happy to take questions
thank you Tony for that informative
presentation it is time for Q&A so if
you have a question you'd like to ask
Tony Harrison please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is can
TLC be diluted yeah actually that's a
very interesting question and very
pertinent really it can certainly be
diluted and although we talk about parts
per billion of total organic carbon in
fact it is measured it is a sorry a
measure of mass of carbon atoms in
micrograms per liter so if a toc
excursion happens in the water loop when
it enters into the loop storage tank it
gets diluted by the large volume of
water in the storage tank and is
effectively removed and subsequent water
samples taken to support root-cause
investigations will not contain
sufficient concentrations of the organic
contamination to be effective and that's
why the p80 700 automatically traps a
sample of the contaminated water for
further analysis those supporting root
cause investigation why does the
European pharmacopoeia call for complete
oxidation of the organic contamination
so as I mentioned in the presentation
they're the total organic carbon is
measured by oxidizing the organic
materials carbon dioxide then measuring
the increase in conductivity that this
actually creates so if you don't
completely oxidize all of the organic
contamination to carbon dioxide then you
won't accurately measure the TOC in the
water so flow-through TOC analyzers
which have a fixed oxidation time can
struggle to measure TOC excursions
that's why the p80 700 traps the sample
and for analysis and monitors the change
in the sample conductivity until it
stops changing ie all of the organic is
be completely oxidized to give an
accurate measurement what happens to the
effectiveness of toc analysis is the UV
lamp fails prematurely yes another good
question so the UV lamp is in fact the
toc analyzer engine if you like and
without the UV lamp
there's no oxidation of the organics and
no TOC measurement now unbelievably most
TOC analyzers do not monitor the UV lamp
light output so if the lamp fails
prematurely then the analyzer will not
measure TOC and won't report any TOC
excursions
now this risks the problem of drug
product being released onto the market
out of specification leading to
subsequent product recall when the error
is detected by the QC lab analysis and
that's why the p80 700 monitors the UV
lamp light output and has a standby UV
lamp which automatically switches in if
the main lamp fails I would like to once
again thank Tony Harrison for his
presentation do you have any final
comments no just thank everybody for
listening to their and I hope it was
informative well thank you once again I
would also like to thank our sponsor
Beckman Coulter Lifesciences for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through June 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye thank you